I'm going to start boxing up my books
and my heart really hurts.
A Florida
elementary school teacher
says she removed the books
from her classroom library
to comply with the new state law.
I decided to remove the books
from my classroom library
out of necessity.
It wasn't really a choice.
Our district gave us an initiative.
So districts are scrambling
to try and keep up with this legislation.
They're already
understaffed, underfunded,
and it's
causing a lot of chaos
within the district.
So my particular district was
they decided to have teachers
remove access
to all classroom libraries
and media centers
until all books could be vetted.
Duval County
Public Schools has directed
teachers to use only approved books,
while Media Center
and classroom
library books are reviewed by
a certified media specialist.
My students were extremely upset
and they,
you know,
the first thing they did, they walked in
and they looked to the corner
where our little free
library is that we keep
and they just said,
where are our books at?
What did you do with our books?
Are you are you moving the library?
What's happening?
School districts across the state
are implementing a contentious law.
Republican Governor Ron
DeSantis signed last summer.
It's all part of his push to legislate
what is taught in Florida classrooms,
including topics
related to race and sexual orientation.
HB 1467 calls
for, quote, curriculum transparency
and says
all library materials
should be, quote, free of pornography.
It also requires
that books be vetted by a media
specialist certified by the state
video showing empty library
shelves went viral.
But a Duval district
spokesman said
it didn't show, quote,
the other side of the library
fully stocked and open to students
I'm shocked and I'm confused.
And there's so much political posturing
and there's so much confusion.
I truly feel in my heart
like public schools
are being set up to fail.
A Duval spokesman
says during the book review
period, quote,
There should not be a case
when a classroom doesn't have any books.
And that, quote, the list of approved
books grows every day.